equally people can be very very unhappy
at seeing friends change and grow
because it often highlights their lack
of change and their lack of growth
what would you say to people who have a
desire to make change in their life
but don't necessarily have that
support that community and they've got
that fear of of the
um being ostracized for doing it
first of all um
i want to expect deep compassion because
that has
uh you said i studied what i lacked um
and so yes when you
when you undertake this
um and again this isn't like you know uh
you know a slot machine put the
thing in and pull the lever or something
like that but um
when you undertake this kind of journey
you yeah you will lose
you will lose relationships i don't want
to i don't want to mince that at all
i have i have
a marriage right it's and that's not to
make
myself heroic i also did shitty things
that caused the demise
okay um i don't wanna i don't wanna
avoid responsibility but
it's fair to say that was also a factor
i can say that i think honestly
i think the person who was involved
would say that honestly too
um so and you know you can uh
and and that's a difficult thing we
sometimes face in our relationships
when we realize that you know
there's a significant a significant
differential
and our growth arcs like and that can be
extremely
and i think that's not recognized enough
as a problem in our relationships and
the problem is because of the decadent
romanticism of our culture
we basically try to turn our romantic
relationships into a religion
uh and so we put tremendous pressure on
them and they they really can't bear it
they really can't bear it and we should
stop doing that we need other things
um and i'm guilty of that too i like
again i'm guilty of that too
i do it i've done it recently and it's
been problematic and
i have to take a step back and go oh
crap i'm doing that i speak about this
and
here i am doing it right and so
all of this stuff is going to
it's yeah you're going to lose
relationships
um but what seems to be the case
is you will
you will gain a and i'm playing on this
word i want it to mean both
meanings you will gain virtuosity and
that virtuosity will
allow you to discern but also attract to
you
kind of people who are also seeking
virtuosity
and so different kinds of relationships
will become available
um to you and it takes
and and and i'm sorry
it takes longer than the lifetime of a
movie that's the problem with movies
we feel wonderful because it only takes
two hours for things to be resolved
and this can be years in the making um
but you will also find friendship where
you might not have found it before you
might find
you might you might befriend your body
and your mind in a way you haven't
before
i have a wooden sword i do tai chi with
and i have befriended that
i have learned how to more deeply
befriend socrates
and spinoza um
so some of their friendships will be
ones that
might not be sort of with um
living people but they'll nevertheless
be living relationships for you
and that is not paradoxical or
self-contradictory
um and then hopefully
again this is not deterministic but it
does increase the probability
that you will more likely come into
the kind of relationship
that is supportive of you cultivating
wisdom i think that's one of the
that's one of the defining differences
between buddies and friends
we call a lot of people our friends but
they're not they're our buddies
a buddy is somebody you enjoy doing
something with and you should have
buddies that's good that's why we have
this term
a friend is somebody that is committed
to you becoming wiser
and you are committed to them becoming
wiser and that's a different thing
entirely
and you will increase your chance of
real friendship
so you might find like again i can't
promise you there isn't an algorithm
here
a magical formula but i have found and
i've seen it in others that you
get a trade-off you know the quantity of
relationships diminishes
whereas the quality of them improves um
and so some of it takes you actually
instead of finding a community sometimes
you have to make it
also so
it can be lonely and it can be
alienating
but it can also if
pursued with a genuine love it can
it can be liberating it can liberate you
and put you into real relationships with
real patterns and real people in real
ways
so that's what i have to say about that
[Music]